on va parler on n'a pas le choix de se
déraillement en noyau qui a beaucoup
fait jaser c'est passé le 3 février
dernier mais ce que surtout fait jaser
c'est l'incendie délibéré qui a été
provoqué par les autorités trois jours
plus tard le 6 février on a reçu les
courriels et nous et d'autres collègues
de la salle des nouvelles en ont reçu
pas mal aussi voici un courriel qui nous
provient d'Antoine poliote qui voit
comme ce qui voit comme suit bonjour une
image représentant la dispersion du
nuage toxique circule suite à la suite
du déraillement de train à noyau
j'aimerais savoir si c'est vrai mais
merci à vous monsieur Pouliot Jeff
allons-y avec les mois que ça a suscité
ouais bon cette carte là s'est retrouvée
absolument sur toutes les plateformes
tous les réseaux sociaux des
innombrables publications contiennent
cette image là c'est pas une carte qui
montre la dispersion des gaz promenant
de l'incendie des produits toxiques j'ai
contacté le NO et américain qui est
l'organisme qui a produit cette carte là
ce qu'on m'a expliqué là c'est que ça
montre la direction des vents le 8
février donc deux jours après
l'incendie en question mais ce qu'on m'a
expliqué c'est que ça ne montre pas la
concentration des gaz toxiques ou rien
comme ça ça monte tout simplement la
direction des vents donc on peut pas
avoir une idée de la toxicité pour les
humains ou quoi que ce soit leur
regardant cette carte là il y a pas
assez d'information et en plus on me dit
c'est que le concentration des produits
chimiques le baisse de façon drastique
le plus on s'éloigne du lieu du
déraillement et là faut se rappeler là
Montréal est à plus de 760 km de
historlestine donc cette carte là ne
peut pas nous donner une idée si oui ou
non il y a eu des produits chimiques qui
ont été déversés au Canada ça c'est un
des éléments de réponse je le rappelle
par les autorités américaines est-ce
qu'on a eu obtenu d'autres éléments de
réponse de chez nous difficile d'obtenir
des réponses de la part du gouvernement
fédéral donc Environnement Canada on les
a contactés pour la première fois
vendredi matin vendredi dernier en ce
moment où on se parle on est jeudi
après-midi 14h30 toujours pas reçu de
réponse de la part d'environnement les
changements climatique du Canada malgré
nos multiples demandes pas encore de
réponse au moment où on enregistre donc
si on a une réponse de piste alors on va
le mettre à l'écran maintenant
à quelques heures de la première
diffusion de l'émission et après de
longs jours de silence environnement
Canada a finalement réagi sur son compte
Twitter en somme après analyse
approfondie des données le gouvernement
fédéral a déterminé qu'il n'y a aucun
risque attendu sur l'environnement ou la
santé de la population canadienne
[Musique]